- Dave, I think we're live brother.
- Okay, cool. It's just on.
- First of all, how are you my friend?
- I'm doing good.
I'm just telling my man I
can't retweet this from main.
I'm doing well.
It's been fun out of the word
but rewarding week
during the Barstool Fund.
So raising a lot of money,
helping a lot of businesses
and trying to get this thing bigger.
And the more money we get
the more business we save,
pretty straight forward.
- Yeah, let's go into that.
So first of all,
before we get into this
little Sunday night chat
I just want to wish
everybody a happy holiday.
Like for the people that are
coming from my community,
yes I was off the grid
that was the plan, no social this week.
And then our very
handsome friend here Dave,
(laughing)
tweeted out something.
I saw it, I was in transit actually
doing some family stuff and,
it was very easy for me to get involved.
I've been kind of off the radar
between closing out the
businesses and for the year
and kind of setting up
this off the grid time.
But I had seen a little
something about this
but I wanted Dave let's
start this conversation.
We're gonna like I promise just now
on the people I just texted.
We'll do a little conversation
about a little small
business and a little sports.
'Cause why not Sunday NFL stuff.
We can talk about the Jeff's game
that just said about the Browns.
We can talk about a
million different things
which I think would be fun.
'Cause we've never really
jammed like this before
but for the main thing and Dustin,
if you can throw up the URL right now,
I know we've got it pinned elsewhere.
For everybody's tuning in right now,
What I wanted to do,
was bring an enormous amount of awareness
to this incredible initiative that the Bo,
I'm so proud of the Barstool family.
I even had to this beautiful
hat I got the other day
from doing the Sunday conversation with,
he's a talent by the way,
that was a fun interview to do.
- Yeah, he's amazing, Caleb.
- So I decided to take, bring it out
because it's just really fun
to watch people do good things.
And I'm going to let you take
over the conversation, Dave,
tell everybody who's not aware
what is the Barstool Fund
and the little origin story about it,
and then we'll get into it.
- Sure so, basically the
Barstool Funds started out,
I don't know, a week
ago maybe 10 days ago,
somewhere around there, it was track,
I think it was probably
closer to eight days.
I wanna rant when New York City,
they closed indoor dining.
And I essentially said, I don't know
what the state the city
expects these people to do,
the restaurant tours, the bars,
if they've already been
squeezed to the end
and they're trying basically
to do everything they can to stay open.
They are being as creative as they can
whether it be creating
the outdoor structure
as the separation, the
air vents you name it,
they're doing it, they're
trying to be so creative
but I don't know how anyone can survive,
when you're not allowed to have customers.
And then the flip side
is you're not being given
any money really to help
get you through this.
So it's a killer.
You can earn a living, but
the tax bill is still coming.
So what are these people supposed to do?
And I ranted about it and a guy
who I really wasn't familiar
with Marcus Limonus
basically he tweeted at me.
He's like, "Hey, loud mouth put your money
where your mouth is."
So, and he's like, "I'll donate.
"If you start to fund
"and put 500K of your own
money into it, I'll match it.
So I was like, "All
right, my original take."
When he said that it was a no brainer.
I was like, "Yo, I will put my money.
"I've been fortunate
in parcel successful."
And then we spoke with Marcus about it
because the, I xxwas like,
well, we're not a charity.
Like I don't know that we wanna
be touching all this money
and moving around and deciding
money was a simple thing.
We talked to Marcus and he works
with the world central
kitchen xxgreat cause,
but when Barstool does
stuff and we have a history
of doing a lot of charity
over the years forever.
But when we do it, we like
to generally control it.
And when I say control it
have a direct say where
the money is going,
know how fast we can get it out.
So Erica and I sat and we
came up with this plan,
which essentially we
started with the 500 grand,
said we want donations.
We joined with a fivexx
Oh one C the 30 day fund.
That was a big, the
original, my hesitation,
it's like, well, we're not charity.
So how are we gonna take money
and let people get right
offs and whatever it may be
and do it all illegally in the right way.
Well, we found the fivexx Oh
one C with the 30 day funding,
and they're like, "We'll
let you use our engine.
And you can do whatever
you want with the money.
Tell us where the money
goes we'll send it."
So that was step one.
And then we came up with this
plan which is essentially,
you needed to fill two requirements.
One, the business, the small business,
we said any small business
who needs help immediately contact us.
Then the requirements being,
you have to prove that
you a successful business
over the course hopefully have
at least a couple of years.
Now, not everyone as you get stories,
there are strange circumstances,
but that's rule one,
because it's basically, we wanted to see,
hey, I've been running
this thing for 10 years.
This is my family for 20 years,
and we've been successful every year
the only thing that
changed was the pandemic,
because then if we're giving money
to them the assumption is
once the pandemic's gone,
they can get back to business as usual.
- They're operators.
- Correct, yes.
- It's not a concept.
- It's not a concept, it's
not something that just,
which is horribly bad luck
that you just started or something
but it's like, well, a
lot of businesses fail.
So we are like trying
to get money do a business
that we have no idea
because that's great but
there's a million out there
that are proven successes.
So you gotta pick and choose your battles.
And number two, we wanted the payroll one.
We wanted to see companies, owners
that were basically still
paying their employees.
A lot of them telling you stories
like I've gone into my
savings, my retirement,
I'm mortgaging stuff,
those speak to us all
to keep their employees
paid and fed and all that.
So if you met those two requirements
from there it's just field,
it's the story, it's the video
that they provide with us.
- Who's on the committee?
And by the way, everybody's
watching or listening,
please go to barstoolfund.com.
So I'll jump in. We'll be
a little helter-skelter.
But I was about to ask
who's making the judgment
on fields that strictly you
that you and Erica, is that
a small little committee?
- Yeah, so we have like
is led by Liz Gonzales
who from the second she's
worked with us has been huge
into philanthropy work at charter before
but she's the initial line of defense.
So we've added more people
going through the emails,
and there's so many of them.
And unfortunately,
so as she goes through them,
some are just discarded.
They don't provide the
information that we need.
So it's like 10,000--
- Like eliminated.
- Yes, 10,000, if you don't come
with what we're asking is tough,
then she narrows it
down, we get the videos
and then I get probably
like 20 to 25 a day,
that I go through and then it's field.
Now, it's also the money has
been flowing pretty nicely.
So we haven't had most of
the ones that get to me
I'm like, yup, yup, yup, yup,
because I'm banking on
working the attorneyxx
to grow get more donations
and we want the money out.
I'd rather run out of
money faster than sitting
on it waiting for other companies.
- So this has been going on
for a little over a week.
- Yup.
- And if I'm looking at
this correctly, Dave,
you've raised $7.4 million.
- Correct, yup 7.4 million,
and I think over 60,000
people have donated.
So it was coming from all
angles, individual $5 donations.
- Oh 67,000 almost 68,000 almost
70,000 people have donated.
And by the way, for the Vayner nation
a lot of people in my ecosystem,
outside of what I did
with the all-in challenge,
and let's just, I'm just gonna,
yeah, so we raised $59 million,
Michael Rubin from
fanatics similar agenda,
a human who wanted to do something.
I got very, very involved
in that one same,
I mean, it's astonishing
that you've raised this much money David,
obviously hit a huge accord
and plus the community
that Barstool has is just remarkable.
Normally 97, eight, 9% of the time
when this happens in my
life, I do what I did,
which was you gave the
shout out, I DMed you,
we had a phone call, I made a commitment,
but kind of knowing that I
had this Sunday afternoon
and just knowing my community
I actually have an inbox email
from somebody who's matching my donation
from another company
that I'm working with.
- That was great.
And that's why I wanted to do it.
And that's one of the things
why reached out to you.
So, and another thing I've been doing,
and I didn't throw it to you because--
- I apologize, I apologize.
So final thought on that
everybody's watching right now
if you have the ability to
support the small businesses
that I kind of kick some tires
and I love the way
they're going through this
to really I think the dollars
are going to the right places.
The reason I'm so
involved in charity water
and xxpencil promises,
the money goes to the thing.
It's not the 30% of the money
going to infrastructure,
if you're lucky enough,
and this is really why we want it,
not we, I and thank you
for coming on, Dave.
What I wanted to do was
really just give a shout out
to my community and saying, hey,
if you can get anything and
especially this is rarely
where I'm at because I
get a thousand emails
like this a month,
which is the greatest gift of my life.
If I've given you advice,
whether it's sports cards
or whether it's been
social media or TikTok
and you felt an economic impact,
if you're in a place where
you can give 1% of that back
into the Barstool Fund right
now by going to the website,
it would mean the world to me,
I just think doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
And so please consider that if you can't,
then that's remarkable I understand,
but I wanted to bring
awareness tonight as well.
So go ahead my friend.
- Yeah, and even I echo what
I think is driving that,
and driving the money and why
you are just so passionately,
the videos that we're putting out
when we call and tell
these business owners,
hey, the fund is gonna be there.
And we tell them, which I don't
think I said the first time.
We're not just there for one month,
we're just not there for two,
we're gonna be there
till the economy opens up
and you can run your business
because what is the point
of giving somebody a check in one month,
and then you disappear in month three
and they're right back in the same spot,
they're in trouble.
We lose the money.
So we have this expanding
payroll basically now.
So everyone who's in the fund,
they can depend on us for that.
Not we get all their tasks.
So it's a lot on our end, like our finance
with xxGM shout out to her,
she's getting there taxes, their rent--
- So you really auditing this businesses.
You're probably making a nine month,
if I was part of team and say,
hey, let's project nine months.
'Cause like, I think
that's best case scenario,
September gets back to normal.
You're probably you're
running those numbers
by the way Hugo, I see
you in the comments yes,
that was me just sending the text.
Dave and I were doing our promotions right
before we went on.
That was my two fucking fingers brother.
Go ahead.
(David laughs)
Yeah, so that's part of it.
And then if you see this
story if you watch the videos
and the reactions that like there's some
that's saying, others are dry cleaner.
- Yet I see you doing FaceTime right?
- Yes, yes.
- And you did like
fucking crying and shit.
- Yes, it's like the move, the bus thing
when they moved the bus
on that old house show and they just,
but they don't know I'm calling,
so it's a little complicated
because FaceTime actually
doesn't let you do voice record.
So I have another guy
who stands behind me,
I do it and then we
merge the sound together.
But it's the most impactful
marketing we can possibly have.
I mean, these people are breaking down
and you see the stress
of these business owners.
- Dave, some people in the comments,
'cause I'm reading along on all platforms.
Thank you everybody who's
on Twitch, Facebook,
all the platforms, LinkedIn,
some people are saying
they can give any amount
is that correct?
- Any amount, yes.
- Fantastic.
Yup, any amount.
- You can actually give,
Morechocolate24, you can give any amount.
I just wanna again, thank everybody,
who's willing to give from
the goodness of their heart.
What's stood out.
What have you learned in a week?
And then by the way, I know
a lot of people are asking
for us to do a little entertainment.
We'll talk a little sports in a minute.
I actually wanna see where you
are on the sports card thing,
because I've been dying
to ask you about that.
But anyway, what's stood out?
- The hardest part I think
and it shouldn't be surprising
is these small business owners
really don't want the money,
like they need it.
But there's an element like I try my best
not to notice it.
- About pride?
- No, they don't wanna
feel like it's charity,
they wanna work.
So I've done my best not
to call this like a charity
like we're just helping you,
but they're running,
there is an element of psychology.
- I have people I'm starting to throw up.
Have people said, "I'm gonna
pay you back like (indistinct)
that yeah.
I get it, listen I fucking get, bro.
I don't wanna own
anybody, any, like I get,
like I understand that shit.
- Yeah, and there's an element
like you're taking mine,
I've been successful.
I'm running, I shouldn't
like I shouldn't pee here
and it's to no fault of
their own that they are.
- This is some fucking present,
it's not the fucking ones
in everyone 100 years shit.
And by the way, one of the things
that really pulled my heart
strings on this whole thing
and I've been doing some
things behind the scenes
of why I really jumped on your thing here
is it was a luck of the draw fucking game.
- Yeah.
- Like my dad, I grew up in a liquor store
that has done well in this environment.
- Is that--
- Go ahead.
- Is geography?
I mean, you can be 100
yards away from something
in the same business.
We did a yoga that we gave
to a yoga studio today
and she sang and it makes sense,
she's like our people don't move.
We put mask six feet across.
They can wear a mask and
you can get on an airplane.
- And by the way, on the record,
I'm not government bashing either
'cause this is fucking hard.
The whole thing is fucking hard.
The whole fucking thing
like Sweden was unstoppable.
I'm simply worried like
they're getting fucking hard.
- The number one thing was, I agree,
and I think a large degree
the frustration is like,
they're not being communicated with.
They're like, there's no plan.
Like what we were just
sitting twiddling in the wind
and that's incredibly frustrating.
- And to me, what really
is interesting about this,
and again, I felt the highs of
this when I was really scared
in March and April for my
own fucking businesses,
but with Rubin on all-in challenge was,
and then we live in an
internet world in a,
we, you and I live in a country
that does have the freedom
to just do shit,
in comparison to other
places in the world,
here the fuck we are to fucking go,
to just sit in here,
and you and your incredible
team have reached $7.5 million
in 10 fucking days.
- It's incredible. It is.
- It speaks to like, or
you could just do shit.
- Right, and that was essentially this,
and that was Marcus as far as I were.
Yeah, let's do something.
I wish we did earlier
because there's so many
businesses that have already gone.
You walk around New York city
you see boards up everywhere,
it's super depressing.
- Yeah, what else can we touch on?
And then by the way, everybody
I see all your comments,
if you wanna ask questions happy to answer
or ask the questions.
Anything else that we
wanna give some away--
- No.
Then let's talk a little opening NBA
in a little late football and a little bit
of the Barstool Market
- Yeah, no, I think that's about it.
If you go to the Barstool
funny you can see the stories,
if you go to my Instagram
still presidente,
all the stories are there every--
- And throw up his Instagram and Twitter
and also throw up some of the,
I see the donations coming in.
I think Dustin, if you can
get crazy on the ones and twos
behind the scenes here and
throw up some of the people,
I love them to get a little
exposure a little love.
Keep going, Dave. I'm sorry.
- No, that's it just
like I watch the stories
and my guess is if you
take a couple minutes
to look at these people's
reactions, you'll donate
because you'll feel it,
you'll feel it in your bones.
- Well listen, I wanna,
before we segue into some other content
and we'll come back to it at the end.
I just wanna thank you for reaching out
and letting me be a part of this.
- No, I'm glad. I mean, you are,
the internet such a deep place,
obviously note knew who you are,
you are the one of the
most of requested people.
The other people somewhere
and I didn't know MrBeast was.
Mr. MrBeast dropped 150
grand in two seconds,
and like I was on the phone
with him three seconds later.
I didn't even eat. I
didn't know who he was.
It's crazy.
- You felt 7 trillion burgers that day.
I know. I know he's telling me about it.
(David laughing)
- Pretty amazing.
What do you think of,
what's your hot take on,
give me some hot sports
takes on the beginning
of the NBA season.
What stands out besides the fact
that I think 20 minutes an hour ago I saw
that the Mavs were beating the--
- 70 and 20 or something.
- 70 and 20 (laughs).
- Yeah, I don't know.
I'm a traditional, I don't
really NBA feels like
it just ended, the
pandemic so jammed together
and it's still, football
to me is the only sport
that kind of works without fans
where it feels sort of similar to agree.
- 100%, if you watched
the game, I couldn't agree
with you more like it's
not so fucking different.
- Right, the NBA, MLB, those
feel really different to me,
without the crowds there's
something off with it.
But I'm curious.
I hate Kyrie. I hate him.
So watching how Brooklyn does
will be interesting to me.
- Listen, I think people
are completely confused
on how good of a basketball
player Kevin Durant is.
I really do I think--
- Well, I don't deny it,
he's the best.
- Right, like I think that's the part
that's been most interesting for me.
I think people with that
kind of injury I get it,
but like 31, 32, isn't 31, 32.
How old are you Dave?
- I'm 43.
- Perfect, so I'm 45.
So like when we grew up those ages,
'cause these guys weren't
working out like this taking care
of themselves, you started getting
into those ages things happened, but now.
- Yeah, and they have the surgeries
and the technologies and the bal
I mean, there's sport guys
bounce back in less than a year
for injuries like knee injuries
that would be career enders.
- Correct, what's your
super root prediction,
right this half second?
- I'm gonna say Buffalo and the Saints.
I'm rooting for Buffalo,
so as you know, Gary,
I am the preeminent
patriot fan in the world.
Ironically,
Bob and Jonathan Graff
called me 10 minutes apart
without knowing they were calling
me to donate this morning.
They had no idea the other one called.
I love Buffalo fans.
I love them.
I love the city.
I hope for their sake if they
can get there and I'm ruined,
for the first time ever the
patriots, they're not involved,
so I don't have hate towards anybody else.
It's like, I'm just
watching from the sidelines,
so I'm rooting for Buffalo.
And I think they're pretty good,
the Chiefs I think could be got.
- Yeah, so I'm a little bit
in a different place than you.
- Yeah, you're in a funny laugh
on wild laugh at you place.
- I'm in a place where like,
I wanna punch Josh Allen
in the fucking face.
Like I said to my friend,
Lou today I'm like,
you know it's gonna be Buffalo and Tampa
and I'm not even gonna
watch that fucking game.
Like I'm in such a dog
shit place all those years
when Buffalo and Miami were
straight dog shit, dog shit.
But it was the two decades to be dog shit,
because it didn't matter.
- Right.
- That's what a second
best team in that division
for all that time,
if you weren't getting past New England.
And so now finally the
fucking turntable turns,
finally Tom's out of there.
Finally, there's a glimmer
of something of what happens,
Buffalo and fucking Miami arising.
And I'm in straight dog shit land.
I'm so fucking being a Jets and Knicks fan
for the last 20 years is like,
really fucking interesting shit.
- Yeah, it's bad.
One of my good friends is
the Jets GM, Joe Douglas.
- He's the best.
I love Joe so fucking much like honestly,
the only thing that is even
making me kind of like cool,
is I believe in Joe so much,
I'm devastated.
Listen, I don't think you can even begin
to truly analyze Sam Darnold like,
I don't know what,
it's not that I wanted Trevor Lawrence,
I wanted Joe to have the
option to be able to trade it
for seven top 100 picks
if he wanted to continue
down the Darnold path.
But like, I mean, I'll be
texting Joe every day starting,
probably right after this call
to trade the second pick for a hall,
because I think we have
so many things we have
to build around.
- Yeah, so he went to school
with one of my best friends,
- Ralph Richmond, yeah.
So I've known him forever
like Newport summers back,
college years, I've known him
forever since his first job.
So yeah, I actually don't hate Darnold.
I don't think I agree with you.
I don't think you need
to evaluate him yet.
- Yeah, I'm gonna Joe fucking borough,
the guy that kissing baby.
- Yeah, I feel so bad.
- That's so bad.
Like it's tough anyway,
I'm fucking sick of that.
What about, tell us something
about something else.
What do you think about
all the exhibition boxing?
What's your take on all
the stuff we're seeing in--
- It's brilliant.
And so I bought a boxing
league, not like that
but we bought something
called the Rough and Rowdy,
probably like four years.
- If you talk to Erica about this
about three and a half
years ago, three years ago
she was in my office.
We were talking about something else.
I actually think what you did
with that is actually the seed
and precursor to what we're seeing.
I actually think Barstool is
not getting enough credit.
And not that you're out
there for credit or things,
it's always execution.
- Right.
- But like those pay-per-view numbers,
like I would watch nine
hours of YouTube videos
of two random fucking guys
trying to punch each other
bear enough Kimbo, you know Slice
- Yeah, Kimbo the old Kimbo.
What's his name?
That sounds a guy who's
(indistinct) was one of those guys.
- Right, so like, to me I
thought you created the precursor
in a lot of ways to the pay-per-view,
then the Paul brothers
have built on top of it.
And now we're like
really in like real land,
and I think it's like
really a fucking thing.
- It is.
And we actually tried to
get Jay Paul, the fight
in Rough and Rowdy way back one,
though I agree is a thing.
And I think Jake Paul's next
fight is gonna be enormous
because of what he did in his last one
where the bubble bursts is
if people start to be like,
well, these guys can't fight.
Like they're Jake Paul did the best thing
that you can do for any fight game.
He created an entry with
a spectacular knockout
of a pro Durand's and the next--
- Yeah, no listen, I'm a big Nate fan.
I like him as a human.
And he's a Nate and all that good stuff
but he's a real athlete.
- I thought he was gonna win.
I would've bet on Nate
because of what you, I was
like, no, this guy's an NBA
he can donkeys like NBA athlete.
- What people are missing
is that the Paul brothers
are really, really spending
a fuck load of time tick.
- Yes.
- Like when people saw that we were on,
they're like you two
should fight for charity.
And I was like, man, if we
took nine months to train,
we would be totally different
animals than we are right now.
And both of us,
and again, we don't super
duper know each other
but from everything I know
of what you've created
and like how you navigate,
we would both be so
scared shitless to lose
and have been know in
perpetuity on the internet.
Like I would fucking quit my
career to finally not fight.
I'd just be too scared for that
video to loop in perpetuity.
- I know, I would never
agree to fight anybody,
my shoulders would pop
out it'll be disaster.
That's why I bought the league,
but yeah they're taken seriously.
And we had, who's absolutely
I'm drawing a blank.
My favorite guy, Teddy, Teddy
Atlas on talking about it.
And he says, the other
guy has been in the ring.
He says, you can train, you
can do this, his phrase.
When the ninjas come over the wall
it's a different vehicle.
It's a different piece store.
Mike Tyson, everybody has a
plan until you get punched
in the face.
So it's just a different
sport and a technique
and all of that.
But what he did is he created
xxGuinness good fight.
That's what he just created.
- The other thing is these
people have real audiences.
Like the other--
- Jews.
- The other thing that
I think is not talked
about enough is brand Nostalgia.
You look at Tyson Jones,
do you know how much money I would pay
for Larry Bird versus Magic Johnson,
one-on-one right now, Dave?
- Yes.
- Do you know what,
I would pay (indistinct)
pay-per-view to 21,
one-on-one give those guys six months
to fucking shred it up,
get their shit together.
I wouldn't be, but that
one-on-one or Dion,
how about Dion versus
Bo Jackson in a race?
- In a race.
- Because I've always said this
from a business standpoint,
Nostalgia is wildly fucking under priced.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- Like to me, I would beat
Gaga on all day Saturday
on social and have buddies
over Bird, Magic one-on-one,
I did not.
- I don't get as like, I didn't care
about the Tyson fight
in a prom like to do--
- You know why, because you
knew it was an exhibition,
it's the same reason the same,
you knew that Jake and Nate were fighting.
- Yeah, right.
- Whereas there's very different rules.
I think that has the ability
to undermine the Mayweather,
Logan Paul fight it's an exhibition.
It's different than
what Jake and Nate did.
- So then you have to do,
and you're right on that,
because even if you looked
at like the Tiger versus Phil
that sucked because they didn't care.
And it was like they're joking around.
- Which is why I think the
inner, and you notice this is,
this is the, I mean, look both
of our careers have benefited
from the deep centralization of media.
The internet is the middleman.
You get anybody, anybody that
has audience, has intrigued,
you look what Jake's doing now,
like we're making this coating,
these 45 other people right
now is truly fucking intense.
- Yeah, now right it's brilliant.
- How much is it show? How much is it not?
It's always a mix of two but here's
what it comes down to for example.
Dave, I am really fucking
good at bubble hockey.
- Yeah, right I know it.
- Like really good at it.
Are you good at it?
- What is that?
- Are you good at it?
- Yeah, I used to be.
You're talking to Russia
U.S.A. with the blue button?
- Yes, to me I think right now,
if we get a little spicy
here with each other
and get into a seven game
fucking series on bubble hockey,
that I'll fuck all more people
than people would ever think
would fucking watch that shit.
- I agree with it.
- And by the way,
talking about caring,
if I lose that, I disappear.
And by the way, here come
all the comments like Dave,
you gotta do is get Gary
V off the fucking world.
But like to me, I punched the
fucking like to your point.
If people care, if two people care
about anything darts,
fighting, one-on-one,
bubble fucking hockey--
- If people care and their
stakes, you're through in it.
- And their stakes when
people fucking watch.
- Right, 100%.
- When people watch,
now you get into pride,
fuck money, fuck promotion,
you get into fucking pride.
Like Nate, I don't know
how educated people are
but I know you are, Nate
Robinson is not only
a real basketball player, he's
one of the great athletes.
The guy (indistinct) top
60 picks in the NFL draft,
like he's an incredible athlete.
- That's why he was so
stunning to me, yes.
And now what's his legacy?
It could be him lying on
the ground, it's crazy.
- This is what really upsets
me because I love him so much.
To me, his legacy, like that
image is hard to fucking erase.
- Yes.
- The guy has won slam dunk contest
he's done incredible things
that he's an incredible
time guy and athlete,
and it hurts and I think that's what goes
into like I'm not kidding.
I don't know how,
I assume like I'm
uncomfortably competitive
like having you go like this
and the whole Barstool mafia shiting on me
when you win game six,
and bubble hockey is
something I can't live with
which is why I would go
into that fucking scared and focused.
- Right, yeah listen, I'm
not gonna sit here like,
I don't know how much
bubble hockey you play,
and that's the only reason
I'm restraining like--
- By the way I don't play any,
I haven't played bubble
hockey in three years.
But it's less about, I'm
actually talking theory
than setting up a bubble
hockey center of enthusiasm.
- Yeah, I thought we'd
gone out of bubble hockey
it's like I was already texting down here
to get me a bubble hockey.
- I'm wrestling, right?
You think about all these muscle heads on,
like the gram all looking Jack the shit.
You get two people with 5 million audience
that fucking arm wrestling
thing is gonna be fucking crazy.
- Anything, I mean is
obviously huge pressure.
And what he's doing is brilliant.
I said in right when,
because it was an interesting
reaction, Jake Paul,
we had him on and it wasn't really fair
because every like me,
I said I think you're gonna lose.
And then when he won, everybody's like,
he just beat him like an athlete.
And people hate him,
in there and he called out Connor McGregor
and everyone was like, you're an asshole,
why would he call Connor McGregor?
It's like, because he's brilliant because,
and by the way I think he's
gonna fight McGregor immensely
because McGregor's gonna
take a huge fat paycheck
for not even having to risk anything.
- But that's where it
gets interesting like,
to me risk anything, right?
So for example,
Logan Paul is dramatically
bigger than (indistinct)
- Oh he is, I said--
- Dramatically.
- I said, I thought Mayweather, excuse me,
yeah, I thought Mayweather
versus Connor would be
a bigger mismatch than
Logan versus McGregor
because the size difference
I thought Mayweather was
at that fight just totally.
He's like, whenever I feel like I can just
put this guy away I can do it.
You're right he's way bigger.
- Like way bigger.
And like, by the way, let's
talk about what they're doing.
They're doing fighting.
- Right.
- One punch.
- Right, boxing versus the others.
So I think that fight now,
I'd guess Dylan Dennis is
gonna loose when he fights next
which is a far different
fight than what he just did.
But if he be still in Dennis,
he's gonna get one of the bigger paydays
in fighting he will.
- I actually think that this entire genre
can be incredible for boxing,
because if you think about it
if you think about, let's
talk about Joshua Fury.
Let's just talk about that fight.
- Yeah.
- If the three of the
four under cards are,
Bob Memory versus you like--
- I don't like my name being
said in the same sentence
for that guy, now that guy
if I chose him pop out,
but go ahead.
- But I'm saying people
that are popping, right.
People that are popping,
you look at what Dwayne Wade's
like culturally relevant,
if Dwayne Wade decides to,
like box a former
basketball, Tracy McGrady
like the under cards of
actual big boxing events.
- Yeah, I mean it's in--
- You changed the pay-per-view
numbers dramatically.
- Big time, big time.
It's an interesting
thing on a lot of levels
because I could see people
saying it's horrific
for boxing on the other side
because the true purists for the game,
these guys are in gyms, make
enough and sweat and away.
And you see a guy that
is basically now getting
the biggest paydays in the game
and he's not a real boxer they say,
I can see how that would
be extremely frustrating
for somebody in it.
- Dave, they also said
hip hop was real music
when you and I were kids.
- Yeah, is that true, no.
- I mean like cool.
They told me that the internet businesses
weren't real businesses
literally my fucking pays
when I was 19 internet businesses
aren't real businesses.
Like I don't give a shit what
fucking people said is real
or isn't the consumer decide.
- Correct, but there is an element
of this is supposed to be a sport
where it's sport versus entertainment,
sport versus entertainment business
- Dave, it was people that
said golf isn't a real sport,
you know this is a huge debate.
- Right, but I get it's like
almost we're getting in,
you're like Anna Kournikova won a tennis.
Like she never wins, but
she's getting the most money
because she's gorgeous.
But it's like people UMass,
like while she knows all this events.
- She's getting the most
money off the court, right.
- Correct.
- She's also a top 25
player during that error.
- Yes, but it is that
the name like effortless,
if I was sweating my ass off
in the gym when no followers,
and I know I can go beat him easily
and I see him get all the
headlines on my, I'll be serious.
- He spent a decade building an audience.
- Oh yes but not through boxing.
- People think that you're
fucking, this is an oh
like I laugh at people
when they talk about this.
- Yeah right I quit but--
- I'm like, we're not right on every 15
to 25 year old giving a fuck.
I'm sorry that you feel you
made a nice print magazine
around sport like fuck you
like the consumer decides now,
on the flip side, I'll go watch,
I'll watch the Canelo
fight and love the defense.
And like both are super fascinating to me.
Like I'm actually a humongous boxing fan
and actually love defensive
fighters everybody hates them
because I'm fascinated
I mean, Parnell Whitaker
was my favorite fighter growing up.
- Woof sleepy.
- I mean, to me, I just was
fascinated by his ability
to have that kind of defense
and obviously Mayweather
became the 3.0 version of that.
But that doesn't take away the fact
that my juices are gonna
be going the next time
there's a celebrity influencer fight
that I just think is funny and
interesting or I'm freaked.
- 100%, and so we all say
had the version of it.
They had the celebrity boxing a while back
they didn't have the right people
'cause they didn't have
these huge audiences.
- Correct, fox had to get
you to give a about screech.
- Correct.
- The Paul brothers, the
McGregors or the Milik
these people were in
their prime of attention.
these people were in their prime,
who's that guy, who's
the guy with the beards?
It's Dan Bilzerian who's been,
feels a little quieter
than three years ago.
But if he decides, if I hear tomorrow
Bilzerian fighting Steve Aoki.
I'm fucking watching.
- Right yeah, and the
Paul brothers are masters
of the internet.
I mean, you really can't deny that.
So they have the huge
followings and they get it.
He gets it. And when we
to talk to him it's like,
who's your next fight can be?
So wherever I can make the most money,
who I think have the best chance to win.
He's not looking for King Kong.
He's looking for the
most interesting fight
that will allow him to
get to the next fight.
- And for me, people
spend 30, $40 to escape.
We're in the middle of a
global pandemic, right?
So for me, that fight that they promote
and create an intrigue on,
is no different than watching
that incredible Jamie
Fox movie on Disney plus
that just came out sole
or watching Wonder Woman on HBO Max.
It's no different than watching sports.
I love people that are like,
this is fucking stupid.
Why do people spend money on this?
I'm like you spent money
on the NBA league pass
like there's a lot of
people who don't have a fuck
about the NBA like why
is Luca throwing a ball
in a basket so much greater?
Like people are allowed
to have their escapism.
- The market determines
what the market is.
I mean, they wouldn't be doing it
if they weren't selling
all the pay-per-views.
- Dave, I wanted to ask you
this why I texted you back
after our call but we
both have family stuff.
Have you seen the sports card thing?
Has that hit your radar--
- It has.
- Now that I know
that you're 43 it means you live through.
- Yeah, I have, I thought
I was gonna retire
on Phil Plantier here rookie cards.
- No bro, you were more
of a Mike Greenwell
and Ellis (indistinct)
- No, listen, Phil Plantier
here on his stance,
he hit 72 home runs and all
star break his rookie year.
- He was a Padre, right?
He was a Padre that--
- He was.
- My friend Brandon Wodky,
Brandon Wodky big shout out.
He bought so many Phil
Plantier rookie cards.
- I had Phil Plantier in Juan Gonzalez
and those are my two guys.
- I was huge on Greg
Vaughn and Kenny Lofton.
I did well, my two guys kind
of panned out a little--
- And then there was the ones everyone had
the Great Jeffries, the Ricky Jordan.
- Heaven Mars was fucking and
fear for me that one year.
When you first heard this
is all been happening
last two and a half, three years,
did you say like, that's gonna
be a quick fad one month--
- Yeah, I still don't know much about it.
I lived through the earlier ones
like crashed with Beckett's.
So I understand, I see what's going on,
but I am very, I am not wise to it.
- What about this?
To me, it's funny three years ago
when I started talking
about this, I was like,
you start thinking about who
and what, it's interesting.
I feel like almost nobody
does the current pulse
of the culture of sports
and youth like this, right?
Kudos to you, I've never
been able to say that to you,
actually quickly passing at a Knicks game,
I said it to you, but I really believe it.
And I have a lot of respect for it.
I actually think you, I
actually think the organization,
the company has incredible permission
to be a major player in it.
- So I know it's
something we're looking at
and we're aware of very much
so like Eric is involved in it.
We're having different companies approach,
so it is something that
has been percolating now,
I would say for six months
to a year within our company,
like, all right what are
we doing in this space?
Me personally, I haven't
been on the forefront of it.
- I get it. I get it.
What about wrestling?
- We have a lot of
people who love wrestling
I grew up in wrestling.
- You never liked wrestling?
- Oh no, yes.
- Not now.
All right, ready?
- Yeah.
- Top three wrestlers of all time,
I'll start with number three.
I'm gonna give you a few minutes here,
I'm gonna scan the comments
and thank everybody
while everybody's here we've been yapping
down below Barstool Fund.
We started the program with you.
If you're just joining us,
Dave here incredible initiative decided
to fuck this bullshit.
We're gonna help small
businesses literally
in a fucking week and
a half has raised 7.4
lemme see it this updates
yep 7.48 almost $7.5 million
kind of shouted me out
and he was exactly right.
This seems to be up Gary
V's alley it's true.
So I love doing GoFundMe out of nowhere
for small businesses
it's where I come from.
I kind of made a commitment
behind the scenes,
I also then wanted to jam tonight
and just bring a little awareness.
RIP Phil Negro I see that.
That's a great call. That's our era.
But we've been just yapping
and kind of entertaining a
little bit here about sports
which I'm having fun with.
I'm giving Dave a few
minutes to think through
'cause it's incredibly important question,
top three wrestlers of
all time I'm going--
- Yeah, I don't know if
I'm allowed to do this,
but I have two sets of answers.
- Okay, I'm gonna play with you here.
Tell me before don't answer anything.
By the way, the person
who just said Bushwhackers
fuck they got me fired up but,
what do you, explain to me--
- so I have an early era.
I have like King Kong Bundy.
- I got it.
- Then Iron chic.
- No, you got it. You got it.
We've gotta blend the golden
era with (indistinct).
- All of this so you gonna get Stone Cold,
the Rock, all together.
- You're 43, which means you're
in pocket for the Hogan era
and you're in pocket and you're in pocket
for Stone Cold, the
Rock like you're perfect
for this question.
Take a second, take a second
- Are they my favorites?
- These are your favorite
top three wrestlers.
- So there's nothing okay.
- You don't have to win
a debate on (indistinct)
it is your top three favorite
wrestlers of all time.
Let's go with number three.
- This is a ridiculous answer,
but it made me laugh
every time he got the ring
is Iron Mike Sharpe, I loved him.
- Iron Mike Sharpe.
- And he always was, he
was the only wrestler
who had like a thing but he never won.
- You remember Kay Nine and Barry Horowitz
which they were all the same fucking guys.
They would move, all right beautiful.
Dave, honestly we're getting
to know each other here,
that is built a lot of equity with me.
Iron fucking Mike Sharpe.
I can remember Iron Mike
Sharp like very radiant,
so beautiful, number two.
- I loved Junkyard Dog, love Junkyard Dog.
- You loved the fucking chain.
- Yes, and I loved his entrance music.
Another one by Sedust, I
loved his entrance music.
- Another one he was on the door force
and he would head butt?
- Yap, no, he was the best.
And then I guess I gotta do this
because it was mine so when I wrestle
it was my finishing move.
And it was like the only one I could do
well that was my friends,
like my friends.
- I thought you were up to the Iron shit
because the Campbell
clutch, everyone can do.
- Everyone no, Honky-tonk
man, shake, rattle, and roll.
- Wow.
- It's an easy one
to do and then roll over.
(laughing)
- Were you devastated in Summer Slum
when the ultimate warrior
beat the Honky-Tonk man
and took the title?
- No, because I just liked doing the move.
I love the warrior, I love the warrior.
I'll still go back and watch his speeches
every once a while, just to like RIP,
just to like laugh.
- So he was a wrestler
that would make you upset
if they lost 'cause you actually
loved them for a moment.
- I mean, I was a Hunk star guy.
I mean, and when he, one of the great,
I mean, when he came back
with MWO and all that was--
- Insane.
- Spectacular.
- Do you know that that was a
Japanese wrestling storyline?
The shop did a great job
with interpreting like that.
- I didn't know.
- All right.
- And you know who,
my number one was ever in the whole thing.
Like I tend to, I love Mean Jean,
I love Bobby The Brain,
Like those guys are so brilliant,
like some of the best
comedians who ever lived.
- 100%.
- Really, like the stuff they say.
- Man, I was such a big Randy
the Macho man Savage fan.
And when I got to the age
where I knew he was gonna lose
to Hogan in WrestleMania
and lose the title.
And I like for, I was
depressed for the whole week.
- I still use.
So Penn bought us when
Pence thought goes up
I'll put a Rick Flair clip that I like,
I'm the dirtiest player in the game.
Like I'm never gonna
stop getting out of that.
I'll do that.
And when everyone's doubting
me and we ended up being wrong,
it's who is this?
Bobby the Brain, Mr. Perfect.
Mr. Perfect Vignette of
when he's always perfect
one of my favorite ones he
throws the purse catches it.
- In that '80s era, the
way they would hike,
by the time Razor Ramon,
by the time Mr. Perfect,
by the time Zeus would be in the ring.
You were so jerk.
- Yes, yes.
- They did such a great job of like the,
'cause we had Saturday
morning and they do yes
and here they would come and
I was so hardcore wrestling.
I knew that other guys
were in different leagues
and I was (indistinct).
- Mr. Padilla, the million dollar man
he made the kids do a pushup saying,
like just knock them off last one.
He was great, there's a lot of great,
there was a lot of I've tuned out.
I got back in--
- I gotta take care
of something I don't know
what's going on my door.
Can you give, can we go take a step back
we'll come with a little more
talk but can you one more time
for the people that just
joined a little more awareness
the Barstool Fund and ask for
maybe people get involved.
I'll be back in 20 seconds.
- Yeah, Barstool Fund donate.
We're raising money for small business.
He's out. I'm in Miami.
So I had to go shower
and people coming over.
So I don't know how long
this thing is going on
for like six hours.
But in the meantime,
donate barstoolfund.com
you follow it along and
going to my Instagram.
So presented, I go on Barstool sports.
You'll see all the
companies are donating to
and the stories.
I just gave a little
tip that you don't know.
Gary, which is I'm in
Miami. I'm going out.
So I don't have all night.
- Oh right, so you can't,
we're not doing this for nine hours?
- Correct.
(laughing)
- Listen, I'll let you go in a minute.
Let's talk about a couple
of other things '80s style.
Favorite cartoon growing up.
- Scooby-Doo.
- Period, do you remember laughing--
- G.I. JOE
- What about laugh Olympics?
- No, nope. Never saw it.
Never heard of it.
- It was on U.S.A. and it was
like the Scooby-Doobies
versus the Yogi Yahooes.
It was like a 1970s cartoon.
But the gray people was in it.
They reprogrammed it for us.
- No, no idea what that is.
- (indistinct) Punky Brewster.
- What about her hot?
- No, I don't know
whatever you wanted to say.
- She was like, diehard a
crush on Punky Brewster.
- Punky Brewster or Kelly Kapowski?
- Well, you're at different.
You don't even know
where your privates are
during the Punky Brewster
era during the Kelly Kapowski
- Let's go in the middle, Winnie Cooper.
- Well, you got an MSK here.
So it's like, Kelly Kapowski is like--
- All time.
- The sexiest.
Yeah, and Winnie Cooper you wanna marry.
- I understand.
What about He-Man?
Were big on it. Favorite character?
- So on he, I had He-Man
I had Skeletor, who?
- Poresman, somebody
who was all like Moss,
what about Stinkor remember
it's actual a bigger smell.
- Yes, I vaguely remember those.
I had, I had a bunch of those.
I had the weather transformers.
I was big with Dyno bots,
I know all those stuff.
- The last time you cried
because of a sports loss.
I'll give you mine while you're thinking.
- Game Six, red Sox, Bill Buckner.
- You cried?
- Yeah, of course you were fucking young.
- Yeah.
- Too young.
- Yeah, it's hard to cry, Gary,
when my teams win, like every year.
- Actually I went they took it segue.
Let's play a little bit.
So last time you cried
was Bill Buckner game six
which makes a ton of sense.
You were nine I think.
- Yup.
- If I got my math, right?
'cause I would say that time I was 11,
I was born in 75.
- Yeah, because it was
12 at 89 yes correct.
- So that makes a ton of sense.
I can't even fathom
that, literally fathom.
The last time I cried was week one
of the week one, this is crazy week one
of the 97, 98 or 98
season when the Jets lost
to the 49ers when Garrison
Hearst had a 98 yard one
in overtime, because I was so convinced
that was gonna be our squad.
And I literally cried I
was 22 fucking years old.
- I have a video of people who know me,
I'm gonna call on this
because there's a video
of the Patriots who lost to
the Chiefs in New England.
And I was at the game and it
was a regular season game,
and it was in the midst
of our like dynasty.
And I was having an allergic--
- When you guys got blown the fuck out?
- No, it was in New England.
It was when Goodell was
there with the towels.
- Was that the game when--
- We lost that game.
But we lost in Kansas city when everyone's
like the Dynasty dead.
But I was having an allergic reaction,
so it looked like it was crying.
So I just took my camera and made a phone
and seemed like I was crying.
And everyone was like, oh,
it's a regular season game.
- You're 43 years old as a Boston fan,
I have a really interesting question.
So I actually genuinely enjoy
the process of trying to win
like it's fun for me.
- Yeah, sure.
- I really do to your point.
And what an incredible run it's been
for Boston sports over
the last two decades.
Do you feel like when you
were chasing it as a kid
because there was so much bad luck
and you had sad things happen, Louis death
for the (indistinct) like there was,
I mean, I remember when
the part two, one in 15
and the only win was against the Jets
he lost the superbawl to Green Bay.
Is it different now that
you've won all the rings?
Like, is it diff, it has to be.
- I think the red Sox is different.
The Patriots what's that?
- Sure.
- Yeah, that the chase was almost as fun,
then he catch the girls
like, and they won a bunch.
The Patriots are different
and I'm most closely associated with them.
And I have a rivalry with the
commissioner, all that jazz
but the Patriots Dynasty
has never been smooth
in the sense everyone hates them so much.
So, and there's so much, you cheated,
you did this you did that--
- Us against the world fuck you did that.
- Every year it's like, we're
gonna say fuck you to you,
and we're gonna come do it again.
Like even the last time
they won the superbowl
with Brady and Grok
and they make the video
with the bad boys like playing behind it
that you probably puked.
But it was like still here like that.
I love it's like, I love
being in America's face.
- I haven't watched the
last four Superbowls
that the Patriots have been in.
I don't even know anything
about that Falcons game.
It's one of the great decisions
of my life was realizing, wait a minute
if you don't see it, you
don't feel it the same.
- Yeah, so I'm the poor opposite.
I was at the Falcon game.
I was at the Marshawn Lynch,
one yard interception.
I was after the interception
game, the Malcolm Butler
I was slumped in my seat
because you have mixed fans.
And the game was over,
if they ran the ball and
then the interception
I threw my cell phone, I just threw it.
And I had to crawl through
like popcorn and stuff
like 20 rows up in an empty stadium
to find it after the thing was done.
- What about boxing real quick?
I'm gonna let you go in a
second real quick, actually
for everybody's listening.
I know a lot of my community is on here
'cause I'm screaming on my
platforms a couple things.
This Barstool Fund really hit
me, like really hit me here.
I'm a huge fan of Erica,
the C.E.O. of Barstool.
I've known her a long time.
I admire so much of what
this man who's with me, Dave
and that whole crew like
K.F.C. and fucking C.A.T.
And like the whole thing
is just great execution.
I've just a lot of admiration
for winners that win.
And the media execution.
I know plenty of people have
their opinions about Barstool
but just the execution is I'm impressed.
But what you're doing
with this Barstool fund
is a real big deal.
You're really fucking helping people.
I see comments in like,
razzing me, razzing you.
And I'm like this, man's helping people.
- Right?
- You raised almost $8
million in less than two weeks
that are going directly to businesses
who literally, literally,
literally, literally,
potentially would be going out of business
after spending their blood, sweat,
and tears for decades
sometimes into a business
on something that you can't control.
And the fact that from the goodness
of heart and hard work to
build the audience you built
you've been able to create
this event. It's incredible.
So two things foe
everybody who's listening.
One, if you are a business
that has been hit very hard
by the pandemic and you still
have your payroll active.
And if you go to Barstool Fund
I'm sure they'll teach you how
to apply, please, everybody
who's part of my community,
if you're a business that
could benefit from this
especially since I'm
putting personal money
and I would knowing some of those pennies
or dollars are going to is
huge for me, please do that.
For anybody else who's watching,
if you're fortunate enough
to be in a place in your life
where even if you give $50,
if you go to barstoolfund.com
right now like,
that actually is gonna help somebody
in a real, real, real, real way.
And by the way I'm on a lot
of nonprofits as most of you
that follow me know I'm not very loud
about the good things I do.
I don't think guilt thing is fair.
Nobody knows what's going
on behind somebody's door.
So many of you're going
through tons of things,
many of you wanna give
your hard earned money
to things other than small
businesses that hit by pandemic.
And that's incredible.
I love you for that.
And many of you don't wanna
give him that's fucking America
or wherever you are in the world.
It's your choice.
However, if you're interested,
if you're being entertained right now,
listen that's incredible.
Literally I can get $50
that matters, Melissa.
That's actually matters.
So just, I just want to say that again.
And Dave, thank you so much.
Aha 55.55 thank you, Jennifer.
I wanna thank you for
tagging me yesterday.
It really gave me a boost.
- Yeah, no I appreciate
you for having me on
as a spreading the word and
it is, it's great 'cause
it's a needed cause.
And if you go to the Barstool Fund page,
you can figure it out.
And if you go to Barstool, my socials,
you'll see all the stories
and you'll see why it's
an important cause,
it's right out in front of you.
- Okay, but what's in store
for Barstool, just like
for five minutes, I'm gonna let you go
'cause it sounds like you wanna
hit the town hard in Miami
and probably break all the rules
and get the bid and all that.
- Yeah, twice I think.
It's crazy because we
sold obviously the company
to a casino group.
Maybe not obviously, but
Penn national, I got my hat.
So even sell the hats
on the great marketing,
I got people wearing our
stock symbols around but so--
- You got us bark?
- No, nope.
It has been crazy.
It started at 26 when
they did the acquisition
went to 40 Corona hit and went to four
and it's a 95 right now
all in the span of a year.
It's been crazy.
So, but the casino were shut down.
There are openings.
So we're supposed to be
launching the sports books,
sports gambling is legal
so as States legalize it
my focus will be getting our audience
our crowd playing with us.
So that's a huge focus of ours.
- It's funny. Do you know
one of the biggest reasons
I thought sports cards would
come back three years ago was
because of gambling?
- No, why?
- Well, it's another form of gambling.
- Oh yeah, yes absolutely
- In a real meaningful way.
I mean the numbers have been
staggering in that world
and it's, I really, it's funny.
I'm really fascinated by betting.
I think it reminds me of
alcohol in moderation.
I think it's an incredible
additive to the experience.
And I really, obviously
me and you growing up
on the East coast and the towns we grew up
in those zeros we know
a bunch of generates
that have gotten themselves fucked up,
but anything in life comes to balance--
- So legalize vice.
I mean, as alcohol, as
gambling, weed now, you know
that's what it is.
- Pizza is a big thing in your life.
I'm gonna let you go in second.
A bunch of people are like
you two need to do a pizza
and wine thing I think
that's actually a fun idea.
Yeah, huge.
Pizza maybe like the number
one thing people know me by.
- Yeah, you really hit
like a moment there.
It felt like about 18 months ago,
I'm trying to remember when it hit my--
- We do it. I do it every day.
I eat pizza on those site
almost every single day.
The piece of community.
- You read it?
- Yeah, read it.
And I've been doing it now
for like five years straight,
five years.
- What's the highest rate of
pizza of all times I your--
- The two that stick out
Sally's in New Haven,
New Haven Connecticut
gets the piece of capital
of the world, period.
- Is that true?
- Yes.
- I mean, in one mans opinion
or is that like wildly like a big thing
like fucking New Haven,
Connecticut is big.
- They did, they're very aware of it.
There's like books and
movies about it, but it is.
They're all close to certain style,
so your French peppers you
have South French peppers
and Sally's you can throw a baseball one
of the other modern,
- It's like the chili.
It's like the Philly cheese steak thing?
- Yes, I would say that's fair yeah.
And the New York I
liked, John's a Bleaker.
Someone just say Connecticut or New York.
It's New Haven Connecticut is that area,
it's not all Connecticut.
And New York has great pizza.
They have the most of it,
there's a billion as all
bad pizza in New York too.
- If Craft move the team to Hartford
or wherever the fuck he was talking
about moving him to way back
when he first bought do you
think you'd be a Patriots fan
or where you'd have been pissed?
And by the way.
- I don't know.
- You're 43 I'm a little bit
about this bullshit Buffalo
thing you just said,
they fucking dominated our division
in your youth and shit on you.
- Yeah, but it didn't matter
the patrons are so bad.
It wasn't like.
- It does matter.
- No.
- I wanna punch Thurman
Thomas in the throat.
- The Patriots were the worst,
like franchise of all time.
So they were just a
laughing stock so it sucked.
But it didn't matter if it was the bills.
That didn't matter as a 49ers,
it's a matter of as the Cowboys,
like the Patriots aren't gonna
beat these guys. Now, like--
- But they were in division.
- Yeah, but it wasn't like
what you have this anxious
that I can see in your face with--
- It's not fucking
anxious its fucking anger.
- Parcels and Bella cheque and spy gate,
there's that history together
that didn't exist with the bills.
- Other than they shit on you
for like 30 you lost
already games in a row.
- Yeah, but we lost
everybody we were terrible.
All right, Gary, I'm going out.
- What are you gonna do
tonight? I need full details.
Like give me something
you live vicariously
through your feet.
- Key on the river, I've never been
it's a big sun and night spot.
So I'm supposed to be
meeting I'm gonna shower
a moment disaster. And I'm
meeting people in 45 minutes.
I hope you have a really
good time. Happy new year.
Thank you.
Thank you for stepping up
and doing this for small
businesses. I'll hit you up.
I've got more things I want to do.
I'm I've in the whole Vayner X world.
We have a small agency
called the Sasha group
which I do for small businesses.
I needed after my dad.
I'm going to talk to the
president of that company.
We're going to do something in addition
to what I did personally,
with you over the phone.
And I just, I wish you continued success
with this and I hope you
have a great new year's.
I appreciate you too.
Take care.
Bye.